hallo mein name ist supernett sich
willkommen hier zu einem neuen minecraft
video viele fragen sich bestimmt wieder
so waßmann hintergrund ist warum das
eine andere kamera qualität ist das ist
einfach weil ich noch bei meinen eltern
zu hause und da habe ich halt einfach
keine webcam und deswegen und sich dafür
eine dslr kamera als fans kämen jetzt
gerade befinden uns jetzt aber auch
gerade im game und zwar seht ihr schon
harry luca wie kannst du da zocken und
nebenbei aber direkt die ganze die
kamera gucken was ist die sache und das
ist die sache dass sich die sache ja ich
hab das gameplay vorher schon
aufgenommen und es ist wie ihr mich
kennt ein totales gameplay weil ich
einfach nicht gut bin und das ist genau
das worüber ich heute mit euch reden
möchte beim einem kanal ist ja die sache
ich mach ja gaming videos und irgendwie
bin ich da nicht gut drin und iran ich
wie viele kommentare ich immer unter
gaming videos wie sie von wegen luca du
kannst das gar nicht warum abonnieren
dich leute warum schauen die das ist
doch das macht doch keinen sinn und
falls ihr jetzt denkt der labert nur
über das thema mit der d serie weiter
bei den eltern ist und keine anderen
ideen hatte es stimmt ja teilweise also
das ist aber trotzdem thema was ich über
was sich schon länger mal reden wollte
und zwar dieses dass man nicht immer gut
sein muss das ist das muss man einfach
nicht ich war ja bis mittwoch jetzt noch
in wien und am dienstag in wien bei
einem
event was vor game changer hieß wo ich
nicht zu bekommen dass darüber rede aber
da wurde mir auch die frage gestellt im
interview warum gucken mehr als eine
million leute deine videos und ich
meinte museum weil ich das perfekte
beispiel da verbinden dass man nicht in
etwas unglaublich super gut sein muss um
irgendwie damit leute zu unterhalten
oder zum lachen zu bringen setzt sich
gerade wahrscheinlich total bescheuert
an und das wird sich auch selber in
meinen ohren total bescheuert an aber es
stimmt irgendwie natürlich witten
fußballspieler der total schlecht spielt
nie in der champions league den titel
gewinnen oder nie weltmeister werden mit
seinem nationalteam oder so viele fragen
mich immer so jung ich weiß gar nicht
was ich später machen sollen ich bin
schlecht in allem irgendwer sich auf den
punkt kommen soll es hat mir nur gedacht
heute ist halt minecraft tag freitags
kommt ja man minecraft auf meinem kanal
und da hat stelle ich mir halt immer die
frage jeden freitag ok was nämlich auch
weil es macht für mich auf meinem kanal
eigentlich keinen sinn wenn ich sowas
aufnehmen würde wie beispielsweise bett
wars oder survival games oder so werde
ich einfach wirklich nicht gut bin ich
kann das ganze nicht ich war das ganze
irgendwie durch kommentieren
durchschnitt durch witzige szenen durch
einwendungen irgendwie interessant zu
gestalten und deswegen kommt es halt gut
an deswegen wenn irgendwer von euch
beispielsweise auch keine ahnung
irgendwie fußballer werden will
aber ihr könnt nicht gut zocken
irgendwas könnt ihr bestimmt das soll
jetzt gar nicht dieses motivationsschubs
gelaber werden meiner kann man auch
einfach ihn über youtube motivation der
video eingeben oder so aber bei mir ist
halt die sache ich mag dieses spiel gern
und mochte soll früher total gerne und
ich mag zocken und es ist alles nur ich
kann es halt einfach irgendwie nicht so
gut aber es macht mir trotzdem spaß
deswegen versuche ich das beste daraus
zu machen und es deswegen hoch ist weiß
ich habe in letzter zeit oft gesagt dass
meine haut trocken
seht ihr das das geht überhaupt nicht
klar ich weiß ich habe letzter zeit oft
gesagt dass ich mir real machen möchte
das möchte ich auch weil einfach diese
kommentare so ein bisschen die überhand
gewinnen das
heute sagen die gaming lukas das passt
einfach nicht zusammen was auch wirklich
nie ihre oft an so sachen hochgeladen
die clever bord oder akinator wo gaming
gar nicht mal an erster stelle steht
sondern quasi der unterhaltungswert hier
und gaming er hier ist aber bei
minecraft ist es ja gut aufheben
wirklich viel höher ist und der
unterhaltungswert versuche ich dann halt
noch höher zu packen und damit setze ich
mich selbst irgendwie total unter druck
jedes mal viele fragen mich dann auch
immer warum ich überhaupt so schlecht
bin in minecraft minecraft ja eigentlich
total simples spiel ist die sache ist in
minecraft an sich bin ich eigentlich gar
nicht so schlecht also ich kann euch
irgendwie ein haus bauen ich kann euch
sagen wie man weil sie nicht ich kann er
die ganzen grundlegenden sachen sowie
man weise neben schwert oder verzaubert
oder sogar man nur minecraft wird immer
komplexer und es kommen immer mehr
sachen dazu und ich habe beispielsweise
noch kein mal in der 1.9 gespielt und
das ist ein bisschen das ding man muss
nämlich in minecraft sehr viel zeit
investieren und diese zeit fehlt mir ein
wenig die kamera gerade dass der akku
leer geht haben eine kamera die ganze
zeit schon blinkt und ich auch nicht
weiß was ich jetzt genau sagen wollte
ich wollte ich nur sagen sich auch
freunde auch wenn ihr wirklich scheiße
im zocken seit aber um ingame videos
machen wollt dann versucht was drum
herum aufzubauen packt beispielsweise
gameplay den hintergründen und labert
darüber so wie ich es gemacht habe oder
weil sie nicht redet über das spiel
einfach toll dann ist es ja auch einer
gewissen vom gaming aber ihr müsst ja
nicht zocken ich hoffe ihr habt so ein
bisschen die ponte verstanden die ich
euch irgendwie oder nicht ich heute
sagen freunde ich weiß ich bin ich guten
gaming gaming kommt allgemeine nächster
zeit ein bisschen weniger auf einem
kanal sondern mehrere sachen geschrieben
dass ich glaube macht doch mal zeigt
aber dann aufnahme zimmer lokaler held
sagt aber deine schuhe oder dicker was
hast du im kindergarten basteleien
gemacht obwohl mir so viele sachen
geschrieben und mir macht es einfach
viel mehr spaß wirklich so typisch
youtube wieder so broadcast yourself ich
bin derzeit auch in einer
selbstfindungsphase was youtube
angezeigt um als lege mich ganz nah
versuche einfach wieder so die kamera
einzustellen und macht das worauf ich
bock hab und bei gaming ist es halt so
dass ich selber schlecht bin viele das
bemängeln habe ich halt eine lange zeit
versucht das ganze irgendwie cool zu
machen durch
die schnitte et cetera pp allerdings
habe ich halt bock auf links hier man
will ja ich habe ein bisschen angst weil
das die ganzen am himmel ist ich bin in
der rother 2 14 minuten ich glaube das
video wird aber nicht länger als fünf
sechs minuten gehen
ich wollte euch nur sagen freunde
belebende getränk senken konnten live
heißt absolut tanzbar direkte triebfeder
w ohne spaß jetzt musik weckt hier mal
jetzt hier schwarz-weiß freunde wirklich
wenn ihr ein etwas machen wollt dann
lasst euch nicht durch irgendwelche
leute die sagen dass es nicht geht oder
so irgendwo das nicht machen lasst
achtet einfach darauf dass ihr das macht
worauf er bock hat und versuchte was
drum herum zu bauen
auch wenn es nicht ganz so klappt
scheiße bin ich schlecht in der ganzen
kacke wenn ihr bock koch zu werden aber
ihr könnt überhaupt nicht kochen und
könntest irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch
nicht lernen oder so dann schreibt ein
buch über das kochen oder malt bilder
vom vom kochen oder keine ahnung was
euch fehlt immer irgendwas an und so ist
es bei mir mit gaming ich kann nicht
zocken akzeptiert das bitte ich werde
nie zocken können aber ich habe bock ist
zu machen und sn video endet voll
traurig gerade believe in you sing
streams und mach ja verrichtet fäden
bein hoch und dann und nun versucht
dieses video wahrscheinlich überhaupt
keinen sinn ergeben aber ich wollte
irgendwie aufnehmen und dass man so mit
auf den weg geben also keine ahnung hat
sich oberflächlich habe das tut mir sehr
leid wenn es euch trotzdem vielleicht
dinge gefahrenträchtig soll ich das
video überhaupt hochladen warum kommt
vernünftiges video denn morgen zeige ich
euch was ich so im kindergarten an
sachen zusammengebaut hat da sind echt
witzige sachen weil ich habe
beispielsweise autos gebaut
die sahne war nicht aus wie autos oder
morgen kommt gaming aber das sehen wir
ja einmal dann immer am morgen
ich habe euch lieb und ich möchte dass
alles gut ist
tschüss
wir geben alles